This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. All of us are surrounded by brands. Designer brands. Calvin Klein's obsession. Oh, the smell of it. A brand. Bargain shopper brands. You're going to spend $20 every month on paper towels anyway.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我们所有人都被各种品牌包围着。设计师品牌。卡尔文·克莱恩的迷恋。哦，那股气味。一个品牌。精打细算的购物狂品牌。反正你每个月都要花20美元买纸巾。
You're throwing your money away. The mini-share wows are for everything. For every day. Brands were seemingly every demographic slice among us. Good morning. I'm Wilford Brimley and I'd like to talk to you for a few minutes about diabetes. Actually about diabetes. Have you ever stopped to ask, how brands influence you?
你是在白花冤枉钱。迷你份额的赞叹无处不在。为了每一天。品牌似乎渗透到了我们当中的每一个人口群体。早上好。我是威尔福德·布里姆利，我想和大家花几分钟聊聊糖尿病。其实是关于糖尿病的。你有没有停下来问过自己，品牌是如何影响你的？
Is it the slick advertising, the relatable characters, or the story? Lance Armstrong will go out there, you know, with the story of I beat cancer. And I'm going to put on my gear, I'm going to put on that yellow bracelet, I had about 50 of them. This week on Hidden Brain, the psychology of brands and how we relate to them. How companies create a world view around the products they sell, and then get us to make those products, a part of who we are. America's Read knows what it feels like to be an outsider, to be surrounded by strangers and to have to figure out how to fit in. Today, he's a professor of marketing at the University of Pennsylvania.
是华丽的广告、有共鸣的角色，还是故事？兰斯·阿姆斯特朗会走出去，你知道的，带着我战胜癌症的故事。我要穿上我的装备，我要戴上那条黄色手腕带，我大概有50条。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，品牌的心理学以及我们与它们的关系。公司如何围绕他们销售的产品创造一种世界观，然后让我们将这些产品变成我们自身的一部分。阿米尔斯·里德深知作为一个局外人是什么感觉，被陌生人包围，不得不弄清楚如何融入其中。今天，他是宾夕法尼亚大学的市场营销学教授。
But when he was 17, he was the new kid, one of a handful of black students bused to a predominantly white school. He remembered his first day, getting on the bus with the other black kids from far away neighborhoods, they were scared. But we didn't want to show any weakness, so we kind of walled stand and walked in with confidence. And I remember the world stopping and everyone looking up and sort of saying, who are those guys? He wanted to be accepted. So he came up with a plan. He would become a social chameleon. I sort of settled on this idea that I would try to be what was almost like a boundary
但当他17岁时，他是新来的孩子，是少数几个被用校车送到以白人为主的学校的黑人学生之一。他记得第一天，和来自遥远街区的其他黑人孩子一起上车时，他们都很害怕。但我们不想表现出任何软弱，所以我们有点像筑起心墙，充满自信地走了进去。我记得当时世界仿佛停转了，所有人都抬起头，仿佛在说，那些家伙是谁？他渴望被接纳。于是他想出了一个计划。他要成为一个社交变色龙。我最终确定了这样一个想法，即我会努力成为一个几乎像是边界跨越者的人。
spanner. So I hung out with the nerds, I hung out with the jocks, I hung out with the musicians, I hung out with all different groups. And in that sort of social chameleon as I would sort of go from group to group, I would try to kind of fit in in a way that allowed me to have some kind of affiliation with that group. As he spent time with these different clicks, he noticed that each had its own set of badges, its own language.
所以我跟书呆子们混在一起，跟运动员们混在一起，跟音乐家们混在一起，我跟所有不同的群体都混在一起。在那种社交变色龙的过程中，当我从一个群体转到另一个群体时，我会努力融入其中，从而让我能够与那个群体建立某种联系。随着他与这些不同的圈子相处，他注意到每个圈子都有自己的一套标志、自己的语言。
And he realized that if he could speak that language, adopt those badges, he would start to blend in. So he started buying stuff. He started wearing the things the other kids wore. Often, it was about shoes. With the athletes, he wore Nike's. With the musicians, Chuck Taylor's. With the hip-hop kids, Adidas, but without the shoe laces.
他意识到，如果他能说那种语言，采用那些标志，他就会开始融入进去。于是他开始买东西。他开始穿其他孩子穿的衣服。通常，这与鞋子有关。跟运动员在一起时，他穿耐克。跟音乐人们在一起时，穿匡威。跟嘻哈少年们在一起时，穿阿迪达斯，但不要鞋带。
They were like costumes, only deeper. A brand can communicate something. How you wear your pants can communicate something. The particular sort of portfolio of colors that you choose to adorn yourself with can communicate something. America's understood that personal brands are like flags. They tell the world who you are or who you want to be. They telegraph, I'm the smart kid, I'm the rich kid, I'm the athlete. There are forms of self-expression. A brand is so much more than a tagline or a logo.
它们就像戏服，只是更加深刻。一个品牌可以传达某种东西。你穿裤子的方式可以传达某种东西。你选择用来装饰自己的特定颜色组合可以传达某种东西。阿米尔斯明白，个人品牌就像旗帜。它们向世界表明你是谁，或者你想成为谁。它们电报般地传达出：我是聪明的孩子，我是有钱的孩子，我是运动员。这些是自我表达的形式。一个品牌远不止是一个标语或一个标志。
It is more of a meaning system. And so a brand is kind of a promise to deliver on those values and to connect consumers who might have in their minds a sense of synchronicity with what they believe those values are. We'll talk more in the second half of our conversation about the psychology of brands and the link between brands and behavior, but I want to start by looking at some examples of what you're talking about, America's. There are people who say, look brands don't matter, as you said, I just buy what's functional, and then there are people like these characters from the CBC TV show Kim's Convenience.
它更是一个意义系统。因此，品牌可以说是兑现这些价值观的一种承诺，并将那些在心目中对这些价值观有着某种共鸣感的消费者联系起来。在对话的后半部分，我们将更多地讨论品牌心理学以及品牌与行为之间的联系，但我想先看一些关于你所讨论的内容的例子，阿米尔斯。有些人说，看吧，品牌根本不重要，正如你所说，我只买具功能性的东西，然后还有一些人，比如CBC电视节目《金氏便利店》里的这些角色。
What are you doing? Oh, these shoes don't play basketball. They're basketball shoes. You can tell by the little man playing basketball on them. No, your shoes are basketball shoes. My shoes are collector's items. And I intend to keep them that way. Oh, it gets to be bad if you got some breeder juice
你在干什么？哦，这鞋不打篮球。它们是篮球鞋。你可以从鞋上那个打篮球的小人儿看出来。不，你的鞋才是篮球鞋。我的鞋是收藏品。我打算让它们保持原样。哦，要是牛排上沾了点育种员的汁液，那可就糟了，对吧？
on them steaks, huh? Get that breeder away from me! Get your shoes away from my special edition breeder. Dude, I'm not joking. These shoes? They're my legacy. So, talk to me, America's about what's going on here. How can a pair of shoes feel like a legacy?
离我远点，你这个育种员！离我的特别版育种员远点。老兄，我没开玩笑。这双鞋？它们是我的传家宝。所以，阿米尔斯，跟我聊聊这到底是怎么回事。一双鞋怎么能感觉像是一个传家宝呢？
I think that it's very interesting, Shunker, because a pair of shoes, if positioned the right way, can encapsulate a story. And that story might be, for example, a story about success or a story about overcoming the odds or a story about being able to have a kind of level of greatness that you would not be able to have but for the shoes.
我认为这非常有趣，香卡，因为如果定位得当，一双鞋可以浓缩一个故事。而这个故事可能是，例如，一个关于成功的故事，或者一个关于战胜逆境的故事，或者一个关于拥有如果没有这双鞋你就无法拥有的一种伟大水平的故事。
And so when Michael Jordan puts his shoes out there, there is the idea that it is very clear, right? So it says be like Mike, what does that mean? It literally means that if I wear these shoes, I will sort of encapsulate some of that mystique because I am wearing the shoes as well. And so it's a very powerful way that a brand can tell a story that can connect with a person's or a consumer's sense of identity that can then create this sense of legacy that the individual in the clip was referring to.
所以当迈克尔·乔丹推出他的鞋子时，其中蕴含的理念是非常明确的，对吧？所以它说“像迈克一样”，那是什么意思？它字面上的意思就是，如果我穿上这双鞋，我就会某种程度上凝聚那种神秘感，因为我也穿着这双鞋。因此，这是一个非常强大的方式，品牌可以通过它来讲述一个故事，这个故事可以与个人或消费者的认同感联系起来，进而创造出短片中那个人所提到的这种传家宝的感觉。
So when you think about brands in the way that you're describing them, not as tags or even as just as names or commercial, a way to sort of commercially identify a product, but really as stories, as narratives, how valuable are these stories commercially speaking? Oh, there. Tremendously valuable. And the reason that they're valuable is because they create a kind of impervious connection that's hard to break if a consumer connects with a brand or a product in terms of an identity argument.
所以，当你以你所描述的方式思考品牌时——不是将其视为标签、名字或商业手段，不是将其视为一种在商业上识别产品的某种方式，而是真正将其视为故事、叙事——从商业角度来看，这些故事有多大价值？哦，它们。价值巨大。它们之所以有价值，是因为它们建立了一种牢不可破的联系，如果消费者在身份认同的层面上与品牌或产品建立联系，这种联系就很难打破。
Instead of an argument about how better the features are of the product compared to something else they could buy, then what is happening is that there is an installation from the brand's competitive attacks because once a person believes that a brand is part of who they are, then asking them to go to another brand is essentially asking them to change who they are. And that is an incredibly powerful psychological gravitational pull that is really hard to overcome. And that value in terms of customer lifetime value is a real like economic entity because it literally means that the person is gonna be on board
取代那种关于产品的各项功能与他们能买的其他东西相比有多么优越的争论，取而代之的是，品牌受到的竞争攻击将会减少，因为一旦一个人相信某个品牌是他们自身的一部分，那么要求他们转向另一个品牌，本质上就是要求他们改变自己。这是一种极其强大的心理引力，真的很难克服。这种价值就客户终身价值而言是一个真正的经济实体，因为这字面意思就是这个人将长期留在船上，
and be buying for a very long time and be willing to do your own marketing basically for free because they are advocates of the brand. They are what we refer to as brand evangelists because they are now willing to go out there and protect the brand. So that value is massive in terms of creating this type of connection that can last with consumers for a very long time. You've used a technique called social listening to study the fans of a very iconic brand,
并且会长期购买，并且愿意基本上免费为你做自己的营销，因为他们是品牌的拥护者。他们就是我们所说的品牌布道者，因为他们现在愿意走出去保护这个品牌。因此，在创造能够与消费者保持极长连接的这种类型的联系方面，这种价值是巨大的。你曾使用过一种名为“社交聆听”的技术来研究一个极具标志性的品牌的粉丝，
the tech company Apple. What is this technique and what do you observe among Apple fans? This technique called social listening is a combination of artificial intelligence and machine learning where we literally go out into the internet and we identify conversations that people are having online about brands. And what we particularly find with Apple is that there is a special unique kind of conversation quality that happens between very fiercely loyal Apple users. And they talk about the brand in a fascinating way. There is language about the brand that almost feels as if the individual consumer is talking about religion or politics. There's a kind of fierce, very powerful, emotional way that consumers talk about the Apple brand.
即科技公司苹果。这项技术是什么？你在苹果粉丝身上观察到了什么？这项技术被称为社交聆听，是人工智能和机器学习的结合，我们字面意义上进入互联网，识别人们在网上关于品牌的对话。我们特别发现，在苹果公司，忠诚度极高的苹果用户之间存在着一种特殊而独特的对话品质。他们以一种引人入胜的方式谈论这个品牌。关于品牌的语言让人几乎觉得个别消费者是在谈论宗教或政治。消费者谈论苹果品牌时，有一种激烈、非常强大且充满情感的方式。
So today I'm gonna be showing you all of the Apple products that I own, from old to new, everything that I own from Apple. Something else, torture mode. Oh my God, I'm literally obsessed with torture mode. Just because I mentioned that I have an Apple tattoo in my arm. And I wouldn't say I would get it again. I was 100% Apple obsessed. I would say 75% of the conversations that I had ended up talking about Apple in some way.
所以今天我要向大家展示我拥有的所有苹果产品，从旧到新，我从苹果拥有的所有东西。太厉害了，折磨模式。天哪，我简直对折磨模式着迷了。就因为我提到我在胳膊上有个苹果纹身。我不会说我还会再去纹一个。我当时100%沉迷于苹果。我想说，我进行的对话中，有75%最终都以某种方式谈到了苹果。
Right, so it's definitely like... Apple in some way. Right, so it's definitely like, Google it. And so, Apple has been very good at creating this kind of emotional connection such that consumers, once they are on board, Apple can basically say, hey, we would like for you to buy a new charger, which is kind of absurd.
对，所以这绝对就像……以某种方式谈到苹果。对，所以这绝对就像，去谷歌一下。因此，苹果在创造这种情感联系方面非常出色，以至于消费者一旦上船，苹果基本上可以说，嘿，我们希望你买一个新充电器，这有点荒谬。
But consumers are like, sure, I'll do that, because they are so bought in, I'll do that because they are so bought in, whereas they could go to Android and they could not have to ever deal with buying new chargers, et cetera, et cetera, but they're willing to do it. They're willing to stand outside in the cold, shunker, in a line and wait for hours and hours and commiserate with fellow Apple Loyalists to get that shiny new thing in the box. They don't have to do that. There's something that is not rational about this. And it's reflected when we look at and analyze the text conversations that occur between these fiercely loyal Apple folks.
但消费者会觉得，没问题，我会买的，因为他们已经被深度绑定了，我愿意买，因为他们已经被深度绑定了，而他们明明可以去选安卓，从而根本不用再去应付购买新充电器等诸如此类的事情，但他们还是愿意这么做。香卡，他们愿意在寒风中排队几个小时，和身边的其他苹果忠实粉丝一起吐苦水，只为了买到盒子里那个闪闪发光的新玩意儿。他们根本没必要这么做。这里面有些东西是不理性的。当我们观察并分析这些忠实得可怕的苹果粉丝之间发生的文字对话时，这一点就得到了反映。
Now Apple fans might say they are not deluded about their gizmos. They might argue that Apple products are objectively better than other tech products. But America's point is out that you see the same brand loyalty when two products are objectively identical. The example that I always use in my class is a very simple example of over-the-counter pharmaceuticals, the Wal-Mart or the Wal-Green's brand versus Tylenol, and the fact that you can have a product that is essentially identical in terms of its active ingredients, but yet one will cost 27% more in the store, And people know that the Walgreens brand is the same thing as the Tylenol brand.
现在，苹果粉丝可能会说，他们对自己的小玩意儿并没有产生幻觉。他们可能会辩称，苹果产品客观上就是比其他科技产品更好。但阿米尔斯的观点是，当两个产品客观上完全相同时，你也会看到同样的品牌忠诚度。我在课堂上经常举的一个非常简单的例子就是非处方药，沃尔玛或沃尔格林的自有品牌与泰诺相比，事实上，你可以拥有一个在有效成分上本质上完全相同的产品，但在店里，其中一个的售价却会高出27%，而且人们知道沃尔格林的品牌和泰诺的品牌是一回事。
And that entire market for Tylenol actually shouldn't exist if people are rational. But what it says is there's something else above and beyond the features that has utility. You can also see the power of brand loyalty in sports. America has spent a lot of time analyzing fans of the Philadelphia Eagles football team. People like Patrick Muller, who demonstrates his commitment to the Eagles with a massive RV plastered with a team mascot and logo.
如果人们是理性的，泰诺的整个市场其实根本就不应该存在。但这就说明，在功能之外，还有其他具有实用价值的东西。你还可以在体育运动中看到品牌忠诚度的力量。阿米尔斯花了很多时间分析费城老鹰队橄榄球队的粉丝。比如帕特里克·穆勒（Patrick Muller）这样的人，他用一辆印有球队吉祥物和标志的大型房车展示了自己对老鹰队的忠诚。
Eagle 1 is Patrick Muller's $300,000 homage to his beloved Philadelphia Eagles. I'm sure there's not any Eagle fan that has been more to games than I have in the last six years. Since 2006, this eagle has nested at every single game, home and away. Talk about this, America. How do people like Mueller go from being consumers of a product to effectively being ambassadors of the product. The Eagles are intricately connected with the city of Philadelphia, right? The scrappy, gritty city of Philadelphia,
“老鹰1号”是帕特里克·穆勒花费30万美元向他深爱的费城老鹰队致敬的产物。我敢说，在过去的六年里，没有任何一个老鹰队的粉丝比我看过更多的比赛。自2006年以来，这只“老鹰”在每一场比赛中都按时筑巢，无论是主场还是客场。谈谈这个吧，阿米尔斯。像穆勒这样的人是如何从一个产品的消费者转变为该产品的实质性大使的？老鹰队与费城这座城市紧密相连，对吧？那个百折不挠、坚韧不拔的费城，
the underdog Philadelphia, the blue collar Philadelphia and for Patrick, you know, living those values and going to those games and being there when the team is awful and wanting to like represent your city through the sport, through the Eagles. It's something that's a special kind of characteristic, especially in this city,
那个处于劣势的费城，那个蓝领的费城。对帕特里克来说，你知道的，践行这些价值观，去观看那些比赛，在球队表现糟糕时陪伴左右，并渴望通过这项运动、通过老鹰队来代表你的城市。这是一种特殊的性格特质，尤其是在这座城市，
of those fans that are Philly Sports fans, and so for Patrick, he essentially immersed himself into this identity and almost lost himself. His identity, I would say, Shunker is completely fused with being an Eagles fan. He's literally taken this beautiful RV and he's gone to all of the games since 2006. I mean, think about, we gotta have a lot of time
那些费城体育迷身上。因此，对帕特里克而言，他基本上将自己沉浸在这种认同感中，甚至快要迷失了自我。香卡，我想说的是，他的身份认同完全与成为一名老鹰队粉丝融合在了一起。他字面意义上开着这辆漂亮的房车，自2006年以来观看了每一场比赛。我的意思是，想想看，你得有很多闲暇时间，
on your hands, but think about the commitment. Think about the loyalty to do this and to create an image and a spectacle and the Philadelphia Eagles. If you're a brand, you're like, oh my God, how do I clone mullers of the world, right? How do I get all these fans to get so excited that they'll put the tattoo on their body, though? How do I get people to do that to be my sort of walking billboard, my one man, one woman, marketing department for free.
但想想这种奉献精神。想想为了做到这一点而付出的忠诚度，去创造一种形象和奇观，为了费城老鹰队。如果你是一个品牌，你就会想，天哪，我该如何克隆出世上的穆勒们，对吧？我该如何让所有这些粉丝兴奋到愿意把纹身纹在身上呢？我该如何让人愿意这样做，成为我免费的行走的广告牌、我的一人（或一女）营销部门？
And this is beautiful because it points to the fact that if you can kind of do what the Eagles did with respect to keeping consistent and authentic with their story, you can create these types of fans, draw them in and reinforce what they want to try to express to others. And so promoting him and sort of they want to try to express to others. And so promoting him and sort of bringing him to the forefront for the Eagles franchise
这非常美妙，因为它指出了这样一个事实：如果你能做到老鹰队所做的事情——在他们的故事中保持一致和真实，你就能创造出这种类型的粉丝，吸引他们进来，并强化他们想要向他人表达的东西。因此，对于老鹰队特许经营权和橄榄球队来说，推广他并把推到前台，
and football team is a genius thing to do because you're literally just piggybacking on the fact that you've got a hard core evangelist that is so wrapped up in your brand that he's willing to do these things to advocate on your behalf. So if you have companies that actually want to create these brands from scratch to build them up from the ground, lots of companies now recognize, of course, that this is a powerful thing to do, so lots of companies want in on this. Here's a clip from Ellen DeGeneres about one company's efforts to create a distinctive brand. It's a new product from BIC, the Penn Company,
绝对是一个天才的做法，因为你实际上只是在利用这样一个事实：你拥有一个铁杆布道者，他对你的品牌如此痴迷，以至于他愿意做这些事情来代表你发声。因此，如果有些公司实际上想从头开始打造这些品牌，从零开始建立它们，现在许多公司当然认识到这是一件很有力量的事情，所以很多公司都想分一杯羹。这段短片来自埃伦·德杰尼勒斯，讲述了一家公司为打造独特品牌所做出的努力。这是BIC（比克，一家钢笔公司）推出的一款新产品，
and they have a new line of pens called BIC for her. And this is totally real. They're pens just for ladies. I know what you're thinking. It's about damn time. Where have our pens, man? Can you believe this? We've been using man pens all these years.
他们有一系列名为“BIC for her”（女士专属比克）的新笔。这绝对是真的。它们是专为女士设计的笔。我知道你在想什么。真是该死的时候到了。我们的笔去哪儿了，伙计？你能相信吗？这些年我们一直在用男士笔。
Yeah. So what brought you to America? Why did this ad campaign fall flat compared to the stuff that Apple does? The answer is when a company is trying to hone in on a specific identity, to make a connection, a relevant connection to its brand, it has to understand that identity in an almost sociological way. And in the case of Bick for her, I think it's quite clear that the correlation between
是的。那么是什么把你带到了美国？为什么这个广告活动相比于苹果公司所做的事情却反响平平？答案是，当一家公司试图锁定一个特定的身份，以建立联系、建立与其品牌的相关联系时，它必须以一种几乎是社会学的方式去理解这种身份。而在“女士专属比克”的案例中，我认为很明显，
gender and buying pins is zero. And so if you try to tell a story that says, these are the pins for women, then if you don't get immediately thrown out of the building, the question will be, okay, tell me why these, why? Why are these pins, quote, for women? And I think in the specific case of Big For Her, there was nothing underneath the hood, so to speak,
性别与购买钢笔之间的相关性为零。因此，如果你试图讲一个故事，说“这些是女人的笔”，那么如果你没有立刻被赶出大楼，问题就会是：好吧，告诉我为什么是这些，为什么？为什么这些钢笔是所谓的“女人的笔”？我想在“女士专属比克”这个特定案例中，可以说是金玉其外，败絮其中，
Shunker. It was just kind of like perceived as this gimmick. We call this, by the way, Shunker, in the marketing and business world, when you do not know how to market to women, we call it shrink it and pink it. And it's like, it's a huge mistake because you didn't bother to try to women, we call it shrink it and pink it. And it's like, it's a huge mistake because you didn't bother to try to understand women.
香卡。它在某种程度上被视为一种噱头。顺便说一句，香卡，在营销和商业世界里，当人们不知道如何向女性进行营销时，我们称之为“缩小并涂成粉红色”。这就像是一个巨大的错误，因为你甚至懒得去尝试了解女性。我们称之为“缩小并涂成粉红色”。这就像是一个巨大的错误，因为你甚至懒得去尝试了解女性。
That's very clear. And in fact, you went the opposite way in telling a story that would almost be perceived as insulting to women, like taking the feminist movement backwards in terms of identity, because it's like, well, wait a minute, we don't need the pen for women. And so because you didn't understand that identity and you didn't take it seriously,
这非常明显。事实上，你反其道而行之，讲了一个几乎会被女性视为侮辱的故事，在身份认同方面让女权运动开倒车，因为这就像是，等等，我们不需要专为女性设计的笔。因此，因为你不理解那种身份认同，也没有认真对待它，
you didn't study it, you didn't sociologically unpack it and analyze it and try to understand its connection to that specific decision making process, you make dumb mistakes like how BigMade. decision-making process, you make dumb mistakes like how big made. I want to talk a moment about a non-business, non-consumer setting. Republicans and Democrats don't think about their political parties as brands, but it sounds like they almost relate to them in the way people relate to brands. And I'm wondering is the animosity we see in the country between Republicans and Democrats less to do with ideology and more about brand loyalty political parties are indeed brands and what we're witnessing today right now is the almost perverse extreme aspect of when identity and identity loyalty and identity connection
你没有去研究它，没有从社会学角度去剖析、分析它，也没有试图理解它与特定决策过程的联系，所以你才会犯下像比克那样愚蠢的错误。我想花点时间谈谈一个非商业、非消费者的环境。共和党人和民主党人并不认为他们的政党是品牌，但听起来他们与政党的联系方式几乎就像人们与品牌的关系一样。我想知道，我们在国内看到的共和党人和民主党人之间的敌意，是不是与其说是意识形态问题，不如说是品牌忠诚度问题？政党确实是品牌，而我们今天、此时此刻正在目睹的，是当身份认同、身份忠诚以及身份连接彻底失控时，那种近乎变态的极端表现，
goes way off the rails and so the notion that political parties are now becoming tribes is very, very clear and making connections to their identity, right? So if you have a proposition to say, I would like to build a wall to help with immigration, you can make a functional argument about a wall. Or you can do what Republicans did, which is to make an
因此，政党正在变成部落的这种观念是非常非常明确的，并且与他们的身份认同建立了联系，对吧？所以，如果你提出这样一个主张：我想修建一堵墙来协助移民管理，你可以就一堵墙提出一个功能性的论点。或者你可以像共和党人那样做，即提出一个身份认同的论点，说那堵墙代表着把出于各种不同原因我们不希望留在这个国家的某一类人群挡在外面。这是一个身份认同的论点，这是一个群内与群外的论点，这是一个情绪化的论点，诸如此类。在另一边，另一边则认为这堵墙现在代表着与他们的自我认知截然相反的东西。它代表着压迫、歧视，它代表着一切邪恶。因此，双方根本无法就如何通过围绕这堵墙的政策向前推进这一问题展开对话，因为这堵墙现在已经成了身份认同的象征。这完全关乎你的部落。这完全关乎你试图保护的价值观，
identity argument to say that wall represents keeping some group of individuals out that we don't want in this country for lots of different reasons. That's an identity argument, that's an in-group out-group argument, that's an emotional argument, and so on. On the other side, the other side says this wall now represents something that is antithetical to how they see themselves. It represents oppression, discrimination, it represents all things evil. So there's no way to too can have a conversation about trying to settle an issue on how to move forward with a policy around that wall because the wall now has become a symbol of identity. It's all about your tribe. It's all about the values that you are trying to protect,
你坚信你正在努力保护的价值观，正如它们被浓缩在你的特定政治品牌中一样。稍后我们将探讨：当你最喜欢的品牌让你心碎时会发生什么。当阿米尔斯·里德四十岁出头时，医生告诉他他的膝盖状况很糟糕。他需要放弃篮球和跑步。于是他开始寻找对关节更友好的另一项运动。我迷上了骑行，发现了这项运动，并立刻爱上了这种文化。就像许多人一样，我与兰斯·阿姆斯特朗品牌产生了共鸣。
that you believe that you are trying to protect as they are encapsulated in your particular political brand. When we come back, what happens when your favorite brand breaks your heart. When America's Reed was in his early 40s, a doctor told him that his knees were in bad shape. He needed to give a basket ball and running. So he started to look for another sport that would be easier on his joints. I got into cycling and found the sport and fell in love with the culture immediately. And like a lot of people, I connected with the Lance Armstrong brand.
事实上，兰斯·阿姆斯特朗加上耐克再加上阿米尔斯，在我心中等于了一种如此令人向往的东西。阿姆斯特朗是一个靠勇气和胆量骑行的人。如果他的团队能够征服它，兰斯就将我带入了职业骑行的世界，让我真正去观看它，观看环法自行车赛。我爱上了兰斯，因为他的故事，香卡，他战胜癌症的故事，我要穿上我的装备。我要戴上那条黄色手腕带。我大概有50条。
And actually Lance Armstrong plus Nike plus America's equaled something that was so aspirational in my mind. Armstrong is a man who rides on courage and guts. If his team may conquer it, Lance brought me into the world of professional cycling in terms of actually watching it, watching the tour de France. And I fell in love with Lance because his story, Shunker, his story of I beat cancer, I'm gonna put on my gear. I'm gonna put on that yellow bracelet. I had about 50 of them.
还有球衣、鞋套，一切的一切。我去了，我买了他在用的那辆自行车。我会骑出去，我会进入兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的状态。我会想到山里的兰斯·阿姆斯特朗。对我来说，这有着深深的情感触动。我会想到山里的兰斯·阿姆斯特朗。对我来说，这有着深深的情感触动。当一些微小的流言传出，说什么，等一下，人们在指控兰斯·阿姆斯特朗作弊时，
And the jersey, the shoe warm-ups, everything. And I would go, I bought the bike that he used. And I would be out there and I would be channeling Lance Armstrong. I would think about Lance Armstrong in the mountains. And it was for me deeply emotional. I would think about Lance Armstrong in the mountains. And it was for me deeply emotional. And when little whisperings came out that, well, wait a minute, people are accusing Lance Armstrong of cheating.
我是第一个跳出来说，你们错了，绝不可能，这没有发生。刚刚宣布，将对阿姆斯特朗实施终身禁赛，并剥夺他的七个环法冠军头衔。从我身份认同的角度来看，这令人心碎，因为发生的事情是，我失去了自我的一部分。当爆出兰斯·阿姆斯特朗是个骗子、兰斯·阿姆斯特朗是个江湖郎中时。我清楚地记得那天，我把所有的Livestrong和兰斯·阿姆斯特朗装备都找了出来，
I was the first to say, you're wrong, no way this is not happening. Has just announced moments ago, it will ban Armstrong for life and strip him of his seven tour titles. And it was heartbreaking from the perspective of my identity because what happened was, I lost a part of myself. And when it came out that Lance Armstrong is a fraud, Lance Armstrong is a charlatan. I literally remember the day that I went and got all of my live strong and Lance Armstrong gear
把它们装进一个袋子里，扔在了外面。香卡，那感觉几乎就像是一场葬礼。那是一个哀悼的时刻，因为这个标志性的、令人向往的自我原来只是一个肤浅而空洞的骗局。我觉得自己很愚蠢。在这段与他的品牌的恋爱关系中，我觉得自己是个傻瓜，因为我一直在试图强化和表达所有这些后来证明并非事实的价值观。
and I put it in a bag and I set it outside. It was almost like a funeral, Shankar. It was like, it was a moment of grieving because this iconic aspirational self turned out to be a shallow and hollow fraud. And I felt foolish. I felt like I was a fool in that relationship with his brand because I was trying to reinforce and express all of these values that turned out not to be true.
这太有趣了，不是吗？因为在一个层面上，兰斯·阿姆斯特朗表现出色，他战胜癌症，他赢得环法自行车赛，实际上跟你没有任何关系；而他作弊、服用兴奋剂也跟你没有任何关系。然而，当他凯旋时，你为之欢呼；当他跌倒时，你为之悲伤。这，你触及了我认为是消费者与品牌之间身份连接的核心前提的东西，香卡。那就是：一旦我的身份与此融合，我就与他的高潮和低谷保持了同步。尽管他的表现、
It's so interesting isn't it because at one level, Landsam Armstrong doing well, him beating cancer, him winning the Chauda France, really has nothing to do with you and his cheating and his doping also has nothing to do with you. And yet you, you know, triumph to when he triumphed and you grieved when he fell. That's, you're touching on something I think is the key premise of identity connections between consumers and brands, Shunker. And that's the idea is that once my identity fused with that, I was in sync with his highs and lows. And the idea that even though his performance,
他的方法与我毫无关系，但我一直在使用那个故事，不仅在字面意义上的单车骑行中，而且在隐喻意义上的我的人生中。也就是说，当我面临职业生涯或个人生活中的挑战时，我会在脑海中想象骑着自行车的兰斯。我汲取了那种能量、那种来自品牌的动机动力、那种在品牌上镀上的光环、我从品牌中消费的东西。我把它当作我的能量源泉，
his approach had nothing to do with me, I was using that story, not only on the bike in a literal sense, but also kind of in my life, in a figurative sense, in the sense that I would almost think about mentally represent Lance on the bike when I was faced with a challenge in my professional life or in my personal life. And I used that energy, that motivational impetus that's coming from the brand, it's hallowing off the brand, that I'm consuming from the brand. I'm using that for me as a source of energy
它让我能够坚持下去，勇往直前，以及所有与此相关的不同价值观：那种我在单车上付出努力、我勤奋、我相信自己、我相信自己会努力工作并战胜巨大阻碍的想法。因此，尽管这与我毫无关系，但我一直在汲取那种能量。而当我发现这种能量其实是有毒的时，
that allows me to push through, to soldier on, and all of those different values that are associated with, the idea that I'm putting in the work on the bike, I'm diligent, I believe, I believe in myself, I'm gonna work hard and I'm gonna overcome great obstacles. And so, even though it had nothing to do with me, I was drawing upon that energy. And when I found out that the energy was actually poisoned,
它就对我造成了一种深深的失落感。对我而言是一种失落。你与阿米什·巴塔查吉和乔纳森·伯曼共同进行了一项研究，探讨我们有时如何将品牌的有瑕疵方面与我们钦佩的品牌特质进行解耦。如果兰斯·阿姆斯特朗被抓到的是偷窃而不是服用兴奋剂，我在想，你是否能够将你对身为运动员的兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的钦佩与你的厌恶感分离开来？是因为不道德的行为与他的成就在同一领域，才使得它们难以理清吗？在你引用的那篇论文中，我们将你正在讨论的这个概念称为
then it sort of resulted in this deep sense of loss for me. have lost for me. You conducted a study with Ameth Bhattacharji and Jonathan Burman, how we sometimes decouple problematic aspects of a brand with the things that we admire about the brand. If Landsam Strong had been caught stealing rather than doping, I'm wondering if you could have decoupled your admiration for Landsaham strong the athlete with your distaste. Was the fact that the unethical behavior was in the same domain as is accomplishment that made them difficult to disentangle? In the paper that you referenced there, we refer to this notion that you're
道德解耦。它基于这样一个基本前提：如果你有一个你天生倾向于支持的个人，那么我们对心理学的了解是，人类会想方设法为主张支持他们想要支持的个人进行合理的辩护，去维持一个他们想要持有的信念。
talking about as moral decoupling. And so it's based on the fundamental premise that, if there is an individual, that you have a natural inclination to want to support, then what we know about psychology is that humans will figure out ways to rationalize the support for that individual that they want to support to uphold a belief that they want to support to uphold a belief
去支持一个他们想要拥有的信念。因此，他们会试图以允许他们坚持这些信念的方式来解释周围的世界。例如，让我们以泰虎·伍兹为例，他在经历了漫长的沉寂以及身体、职业和个人生活中的诸多打击后，最近复出了。如果你看看他的故事，他做了什么？
that they want to have. And so they will try to interpret the world around them in ways that allow them to uphold those beliefs. So for example, let's take the example of Tiger Woods who recently came back after a long layoff of a lot of tragedy and challenge, both physically, professionally, and personally. If you look at his story, what did he do?
嗯，他背叛了妻子。所以对妻子不忠大概和你的高尔夫球技没有任何关系。因此，如果你渴望支持泰格·伍兹，你可以在心中进行一番心理论证，这恰好反映了道德解耦。你可以说，“嗯，你知道的，我其实并不同意他在私生活里可能做的那些事。不过，我真的很喜欢他的高尔夫球技。”
Well, he cheated on his wife. And so cheating on your wife presumably has nothing to do with your golf game. So if you desired to support Tiger Woods, you could make the mental argument in your mind that would reflect moral decoupling. You could say, well, you know, I don't really agree with this whole thing that he might have been doing in his personal life. However, I really like his golf game.
“所以我将继续支持他。”因此，道德解耦有趣的地方在于，如果名人或这个人做的那件坏事与你所钦佩的表现无关，那么你就可以在心中把它拆解开来，你几乎可以忽略（如果你愿意的话），甚至不去评论那件坏事的道德性，因为你可以简单地专注于表现以及你在那个表现领域钦佩他们所作所为这一事实。因此，这是一个非常有趣的现象，因为对兰斯·阿姆斯特朗而言，
So I'm gonna continue to support him. And so what's interesting about moral decoupling, if that bad thing that the celebrity or the person does is not related to the performance that you admire, then you can pull it apart in your mind and you can almost ignore, if you will, or not even comment on the morality of the bad thing, because you can simply focus on the performance and the fact that you admire what they do in that performance domain. And so it's a very interesting aspect because in the case of Lance Armstrong,
对我来说是不可能的。老天作证，我尝试过了。但要把兰斯·阿姆斯特朗身上的这两件事分离开来，对我来说是不可能的。这就是为什么他所有的衣服最后都堆在了我的人行道上。所以。所以。
it was impossible for me. And I'm gonna tell you the truth. Lord knows I try. But it was impossible for me to pull those two things apart for Lance Armstrong. And that's why all of his clothes ended up on my sidewalk. So. So.
现在，有很多人，阿米尔斯，认为建立品牌的想法简直令人厌恶。这不过是营销人员和巨型公司在愚弄顾客、愚弄消费者。弗兰克·日耳曼、亚伦·加维和丽莎·博尔顿曾经做过一项有趣的关于耐克推杆的研究。当我与弗兰克·日耳曼交谈时，他是这样向我解释这项研究的：
Now, there are lots of people, America, so think that the idea of building a brand is just distasteful. It's just marketers and big companies trying to hoodwink customers, hoodwink consumers. Frank, German, Aaron Garvey and Lisa Bolton once conducted an interesting study involving Nike putters. And when I spoke with Frank, German, here's how he explained the study to me.
大约一半的参与者被告知他们将使用耐克推杆进行推击，而另一半参与者则没有被告知他们将使用什么品牌的推杆。重要的是，所有参与者使用的推杆完全相同。有趣的是，我们的结果显示，那些认为自己使用的是耐克推杆的人，平均需要的推杆次数明显更少，就能把高尔夫球击入洞中。这到底是怎么回事，阿米尔斯？在某种程度上，这与你之前告诉我关于穿着兰斯·阿姆斯特朗装备骑车并感觉自己表现更好的经历有关，但这实际上表明，这不仅仅是一种
About half of the participants were told that they would be putting with a Nike putter, whereas the other half of participants were not told what putter brand they would be using. Importantly, all participants use the exact same putter. And interestingly, our results showed that those who thought that it was an icky putter on average needed significantly fewer putts to sink the golf ball. What's going on here, America? In some ways, this is connected to what you were telling me about wearing your land-sum strong gear and biking and feeling like you were doing better, but this actually suggests this isn't just a
感觉，当你穿着兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的装备时，你的骑行表现可能真的变好了。它字面意义上展示了安慰剂效应，这正是他们在这里真正利用的效应，它是真实存在的。你听过“Just do it”（只管去做）这句话太久了，你相信那个品牌赋予了你表现上的优势。这种优势如此之大，以至于对该品牌的心理感知直接转化为你实际表现的能力，让你能用更少的杆数完成推击。对我来说，这是最显著、最有力的例子，说明了品牌的力量
feeling you actually might have biked better when you are wearing your Landsam strong gear. What it literally shows is the placebo effect, which is what they are really tapping into here, is real. You have been told about just do it for so long, you believe that that brand endows a performance advantage. So much so that the psychological perceptions of that brand literally translate in your ability to actually perform, to make those putts in fewer strokes. And that to me is the most salient and powerful example of this notion that the power of brand
与围绕该品牌的故事或叙事中构建的行为活动的预期高度交织在一起，以至于它们实际上转化为了该品牌在各种实际意图和目的下本不该拥有的优势。我真希望有人能在双盲实验中，在我不知情的情况下，
is so intertwined with the perceived expectations of the behavioral activities that are built into that narrative or that story about the brand, that they literally translate into advantages for the brand that really shouldn't be there for all intents and purposes. I wish someone would have put the metrics on me and done the controlled experiment, where I didn't know at Double Blind,
对我进行各项指标的测量并进行对照实验。测试我穿着和不穿着兰斯·阿姆斯特朗服装骑车时的表现，看看结果如何，因为我敢打赌。我记得有几天我骑着自行车出门。我记得有一次，我骑着自行车。我记得有一次，我试图爬上一座山，当时觉得非常吃力。我低头看了一眼，能看到手腕上的LiveStrong手环，我低头拉开了骑行服的拉链，
where I would be on my bike with and without the Lance Armstrong close, and see, because I would be willing to bet. I remember days going out and riding the bike. I remember this one time and riding the bike. I remember this one time where I was trying to go up this one hill and I was struggling. I looked down and I could see my live strong band on my wrist and I looked down and I unzipped my bike jersey
就像兰斯做的那样。这是兰斯以前准备动真格时常做的一个动作。他会拉开球衣拉链，把帽子转过来。这就像是在向他的竞争对手发出信号：我要开始全力以赴了。我要把这一切提升到一个全新的水平。
like Lance does. This is something Lance used to do when he was about to get serious. He would unzip his jersey and he'd take his cap and he'd flip it around. And he's like, this means that he's signaling to his competitors. I'm about to get very, very like hardcore into this. And I'm about to take it this to a whole new level.
我还记得自己当时那样做了。我还记得自己充满力量地冲上了这座山，到达了山顶，并在脑海中想象着那些兰斯的粉丝。他们会站在山顶为他欢呼。我几乎敢打赌，当我穿着他的装备时，我的表现确实有所提升。你过去曾谈到过品牌重塑如何能够成为一股向善的力量，它可以帮助那些有使命驱动的公司成就伟大的事情。
I remember doing that. And I remember powering through this hill and getting to the top and like imagining in my mind those fans of Lance. That would be at the top of the hill cheering him on. And I almost unwilling to bet that my performance improved when I was wearing his gear. You've talked in the past about how branding can be a force for good, that it can help companies that are mission-driven companies accomplish great things.
但我想知道你是否也可以谈谈品牌建设面临的这一挑战。许多人认为它是操纵性的、不真实的。品牌建设本身是不是存在一个品牌危机？太棒了，我喜欢这个问题，香卡。答案是肯定的。这很不幸，因为品牌建设本身既不好也不坏。所以这有点像我喜欢用的那个比喻，
But I'm wondering if you can also talk a little bit about this challenge that branding has. A lot of people see it as manipulative, see it as inauthentic. Does branding have a branding problem? That's fantastic. I love that question, Shunger. The answer is yes. And it's unfortunate because branding in and of itself is neither inherently good or bad. So it's kind of like the analogy that I like to use,
当我在谈论这个时，品牌营销更普遍地说就像是一把锤子。你可以拿起一把锤子，如果你愿意，你可以为无家可归的人建造一座房子，对吧？但你也可以拿起一把锤子，如果你愿意的话，一锤子砸向老人的脑袋并抢走他们的钱包。
what I'm talking about this is that branding and marketing more generally is like a hammer. And so you can take a hammer, and if you want to, you can build a house for a homeless person, right? But you can also take a hammer, and if you want to knock an elderly person upside their head and take their wallet.
锤子本身并没有什么不好的。关键在于你如何使用它，以及为什么不把它用作变革的力量、用作强大而积极的力量。例如，如果你是一个体育用品公司品牌，难道不是很棒吗？你实际上可以成为消费者的动机动力，激励他们多锻炼身体，为了自己和所爱的人变得更健康。这难道不是一件好事吗？我认为这是一件好事。
There's nothing inherently bad about a hammer. It's how you use it, and why not use it as a force for change as something powerful and positive. For example, if you are a brand that is a sports company, isn't it great that you can actually become the motivational impetus for a consumer to want to exercise more and to make themselves healthier for themselves and their loved ones. Isn't that a good thing? I think that's a good thing.
阿米尔斯·里德是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的心理学家兼市场营销学教授。阿米尔斯，感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你，香卡。很高兴能与你交流。本周的节目由安格斯·陈（Angus Chen）和劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）制作。由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）剪辑。我们的团队包括珍妮许·施密特（Jenish Schmidt）、帕尔斯·沙阿（Parth Shah）和托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）。我们本周的无名英雄是霍瓦娜·梅洛（Hwana Mello）。直到最近，霍瓦娜还在NPR的市场营销部工作。
America's Reed is a psychologist and professor of marketing at the Wharton School at the University of Pennsylvania. America's thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. It was a pleasure to be with you. This week's show was produced by Angus Chen and Laura Quarell. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Jenish Schmidt Parth Shah and Thomas Liu. Our unsung hero this week is Hwana Mello. Until recently, Hwana worked at NPR's marketing department.
她通过设计《隐藏的大脑》标志，帮助我们塑造了视觉形象。作为一名记者，我对故事、写作和编辑思考了很多，但对视觉设计却没有投入太多思考。霍瓦娜在这方面纠正了我，她想出了一种视觉形象，伴随着我们的节目出现在社交媒体和现场活动中。
She helped develop our visual identity by designing the Hidden Brain logo. As a journalist, I thought a lot about stories and writing and editing, but hadn't given much thought to visual design. Hwana set me right on that, and she had come up with a visual identity that travels with our show on social media and at live events.
谢谢你，霍瓦娜！如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》并想听到我们更多的工作成果，也许正当你努力完成一次艰难的骑行时，请务必订阅这个播客。如果你认识会喜欢收听这期节目的朋友，请务必分享给他们。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。
Thanks Hwana! If you enjoy Hidden Brain and want to hear more of our work, maybe as you are powering through a tough bike ride, be sure to subscribe to this podcast. If you know someone who would like to listen to this episode, please be sure to share it with them. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。